san francisco 49ers had the super bowl
in their grasp up 20 to 10 with seven
minutes remaining and then it all fell
apart there is a
an urgency big cat for the 49ers to get
back not to week one but to get back to
the super bowl up 10 points with seven
minutes left and finish the job there
were some comments earlier this week
from coach kyle shanahan saying that's
what they need to do they need to get
back to that point and this time
keep it together and hold the lead
others on the team talking openly about
wanting to get back to the super bowl
and win it
and look a lot of 49ers fans upset that
i'm saying this because we did it
yesterday in pftot and it's already
started to kind of take on a life of its
own i don't like this talk
i don't like fast forwarding to the
super bowl again only two teams in the
history of the super bowl have lost and
gone back and won it the next year you
have been thrust into what dennis green
called the valley of zero and zero you
are starting over again you are in a
division with the seahawks the rams and
the cardinals last year everything had
to fall your way you had to thread the
needle seven times don't shake your head
i'm not done yet this is loser
you had but it's but it's re but but
here's the thing you get all those 49ers
fans lathered up about we're getting
back to the super bowl this year we're
going to win it and you barely make it
to the playoffs and you lose in the
divisional round you're viewed as a
failure they need to be what would bill
belichick do
yeah what would bill belichick do would
bill belichick say any of this stuff or
would he say last year doesn't matter
we're here for this year we know it's
going to be more difficult this year
because everybody's going to be coming
after us and we got to be ready for the
challenge each and every week and if we
take care of that then other things will
take care of themselves not man we can't
wait to get back to the super bowl when
we were leading with seven minutes left
and we blew it that that that puts so
many carts before the horse that is the
first game of the regular season then
the second game of the regular season
because if you're thinking too much
about january you end up not getting
there case in point when the jaguars
beat the patriots in september of 2018
i think in their mind they thought you
know what
we we can beat these guys in the
playoffs we had him beat in january of
this year and bad call kept us from
being up 17 points in the afc
championship game with about 10 minutes
13 minutes left we beat him in september
we're ready we're ready to go let's go
to the super bowl and they forgot about
the fact they had to play a bunch of
games before they go to the super bowl
and i think that's the moment they fell
apart you can't start looking down the
road if you're a football team you've
got to do it week after week after week
you got to build the house one brick at
a time and this kind of talk
gl there's always a team that glosses
over how hard it is to put a great
season together and to go back to zero
and zero and do it again and it's hard
and it's difficult and if and and if you
start looking past games and weeks and
months you're walking into a buzzsaw
that's my opinion and i've seen it
happen enough times that i think i'm
right
okay i
you're just taking the worst
interpretation of what kyle shanahan is
saying here in the worst like possible
situation kyle shanahan's admitting what
we're all thinking
this the 49ers are going to be
in the top five super bowl favorites you
know to get back to win the super bowl
they went there last year there are
expectations there to ignore the
expectations i think is foolish you have
to face those expectations say this is
what we are looking for we are trying to
get back there it's not you don't no
one's saying they're gonna overlook
everything
you knocked down the expectations that's
the point the the the biggest trap that
teams can fall into is number one
allowing expectations to get out of hand
and number two failing to take an
affirmative role in knocking them down
and it's very easy for the coaster and
it's not loser talk it's reality hey
folks go back and look at what we did
last year week by week look at those
games we played look at what the look at
the look the cardinals gave us
everything we could handle twice the
seahawks beat us in our own building we
barely beat them the last game of the
regular season we lose that game we're
the five seed we had to have two third
and longs on the same drive converted in
order to beat the rams this is not easy
folks don't expect us look it's all a
new season it's always easy
but mike if they don't lose if they lose
before the super bowl it's gonna be a
disappointing season regardless if they
lose the super bowl it's gonna be a
disappointing season what are we talking
about what i'm talking about
disappointing
well but that's crap too everybody acts
like they want to win the super bowl so
their fans will be engaged and buy
tickets the reality is if that's how you
judge the success of your franchise
you're going to be upset all the time my
point is this you need look i i always
go back and and it's a copycat league
right and it's amazing how many of the
things that bill belichick does that
others don't copy
and belichick would never allow himself
to step on this rake he would never
allow himself to say and last year is
irrelevant big cat i'm surprised that
you don't that did i don't know if
you're just trying to fashion up a hot
take or push back against me no last
show for three weeks i just don't this
is so fundamental to me why are you why
are you it's last year does not matter
folks we're zero and zero we've got to
worry about the cardinals kyler murray's
on the on the verge of being the next
great star in the nfl the rams are still
great the seahawks have given us
everything we can handle we just got to
get to the playoffs i'm not even sure we
can get to the playoffs and it doesn't
have to come off as the lou holtz
routine where we can lose to
jacksonville state but you know what
there ain't no jacksonville state in
their division they got three
powerhouses in their division they got
to get past them and he needs to send
that message to the fans and he
definitely needs to send that message to
the locker room you can't have guys on
the team talking about we need to get
back and finish the job all we can't
wait to finish the job you're not going
to be in position to finish the job if
you don't take every game seriously and
i i look at bill belichick he would not
allow this thought he would not allow
this talk but mike bill belichick is the
is the exception not the rule though you
know that there are three but shannon
kyle shannon not like shanahan can be
that but but the patriots have a certain
way and guess what you know what bill
belichick also has he has six rings and
you know what that lets him do that lets
him suck all the life out of every
single press conference and suck all the
life out of every locker room and never
talk about anything that's ever fun
because he has results kyle shanahan
saying we have to finish the job that's
a message i have no problem with he
didn't say that we're gonna look past
the entire season he said we have to
finish the job
first of all you prove my point when you
say that bill belichick has six rings
second of all bill belichick is totally
different than everyone else
bill belichick is a curmudgeon they won
because bill belichick's brain is better
than everyone else's
he he was sucking the life out of the
room long before he won super bowl
number six also but guys there's a way
there's a strategy you have to have guys
buy in it's hard to get guys to buy in
and they haven't actually won anything
do you really think do you really think
that belichick is just acting that way
because he wants to or because he
believes that is the appropriate way to
get your team focused i'm stunned that
you don't know
my expectations my expectations for you
apparently were too high i may need to
adjust them over the course of the next
three weeks this is so fundamental this
is so basic last year doesn't matter
last year doesn't matter mike they they
didn't say anything wrong that's the
problem if kyle shanahan had said we'll
be back in the super bowl this is going
to be a cake walk we've done it once
we'll do it again why would nobody's
going to say that all he said was we had
to finish the job what's wrong with
saying what to finish the job if they
don't finish up it's going to be a
disappointment
that's the expectations on this they
need to know they have those
expectations
you're being disingenuous he didn't say
we just have to finish what's up he took
them he took them to that moment the
state of the franchise is we have to the
st i'm trying to will you shut up this
data tell me the quote
do the quote now i'm
i'm waiting for you to stop are you done
yes what do you what he said is we need
to get back to the point where we're
holding the lead in the fourth quarter
of the super bowl and we need to hold
the lead like the easy part is getting
to the point where you're holding the
ten point lead with seven minutes left
in the fourth quarter of the super bowl
and the hard part is holding the lead no
the easy part should be holding the lead
the hardest part by far is getting to
the point where you qualify the for the
playoffs you you get home field
advantage for the playoffs and not have
to go on the road in the wild card round
which they almost had to do you win at
home against the vikings you win at home
against the packers you get to the super
bowl playing against the most dangerous
quarterback that we've seen in years and
somehow build a 10-point lead with seven
minutes left that's the hard part the
easy part is holding that lead i just
don't i just think i think we i'm not
saying
is not saying everything is easy he's
just saying that's where we have to
they're probably the full quote was
probably we have to get back there to
the fourth quarter where we have a lead
in the super bowl and getting back there
is really hard to do
that's probably the problem is but
here's the thing it's one thing to put
your hand in the flame nobody's dumb
enough to do that
you don't even get your hand close to
that flame you don't talk that why do
you think bill belichick doesn't talk
about anything that's happened in the
past he doesn't talk about the
we're on to cincinnati we're on to
cincinnati no you're wrong you're wrong
about that because if you it because let
me tell you every once in a while
someone will ask him some obscure
football strategy question or some old
school thing that used to happen and
he'll talk for 20 minutes about that he
doesn't want to say anything that will
undermine the ability to focus the
players on the task at hand and any
thought about last year does not focus
the players on the task at hand last
year doesn't matter what matters is week
one
week two
week three and if you don't take care of
business one week at a time you're not
going to even have a chance to compete
for the ability to get to the super bowl
and build a lead against patrick mahomes
and try to hold it this time i'm i'm i'm
stunned i'm stunned that you don't see
something that you're there i'm still no
i'm stunned you just made tom brady a
hero given the quotes that he's had
recently
well wait a minute i'm not making tom
bro for what the only thing but maybe
maybe kyle shanahan just should have
said the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself
yeah maybe i said that i went to google
to find kyle shane hayden's exact quotes
and the first result is mike florio
calls kyle jennings
quotes unrealistic
so there we go
we are we are ahead of our time all
right let's take a break liverpool ended
a long premier league drought yesterday
we're gonna have a draft inspired by
that premier league championship when
pft live continues right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports